ja meine these ist dass die abschaffung
die faktische abschaffung der sanktionen
für
kooperationsunwillige hartz 4 bezieher
sowohl ein politischer als auch ein
gesellschaftlicher fehler ist hartz4 hat
von anfang an bedeutet werden bei der
einführung etwa fünf millionen
arbeitslose als angela merkel
bundeskanzlerin wurde fördern und
fordern
der staat fördert die integration oder
wieder integration in den arbeitsmarkt
aber erfordert auch etwas von den
hilfeempfängern nämlich dass sie sich
ernsthaft darum bemühen eine
beschäftigung zu finden das sie zum
beispiel an sprachunterricht teilnehmen
sofern sie nicht in der lage sind in
wort und schrift ruhig machen dass die
deutschkenntnisse auf dem arbeitsmarkt
integriert zu werden dass termine
wahrgenommen werden um schulungsangebote
weiterbildungsangebote wahrgenommen
werden das ist keine große zahl das sind
0,9 prozent die von sanktionen betroffen
waren weil es eben an dieser kooperation
gefehlt hat jetzt sind wir so auf dem
weg zu einer zu einem atem einkommen für
alle
ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
wird's nicht genannt aber wir wandern in
diese richtung gesellschaftlich das ist
ein fehler weil wir nicht nur
verantwortung denen gegenüber tragen die
wir wieder auf dem arbeitsmarkt
integrieren wollen sondern auch
gegenüber denen die hartz4 und die
leistungen bezahlen müssen gegenüber den
steuerzahlerinnen steuerzahler und
gegenüber den beitragszahlern wenn man
pflichten übernimmt aber diese pflichten
schuldhaft verletzt ohne dass es
sanktionen gibt dann nimmt der staat das
was er unterfordert vorsteht selber
nicht ernst stärke wenn sie zustimmt
fordern und fördern
arbeit muss sich lohnen führen sie auch
die sanktionen aufrecht erhalten gegen
hartz 4 empfänger also ich finde es ja
an sich schon immer skurril also wir
haben ja heute also man sieht es ja
finde ich auch oft wenn man durch die
straßen geht also zum beispiel ich wohne
in einem relativ sagen wir mal gut
situierten bezirk und sehe bei mir leute
die zum beispiel auch obdachlos sind die
aber teilweise ganz jung auch sind wo
ich mich dann auf frage warum arbeiten
die leute nicht warum machen sie nichts
denn dahinter harte schicksale vor allem
bei den menschen auf der straße das ist
auch gar nicht schaffen zum amt zu gehen
und sich hilfe zu holen ich bin schon
mal zu ihm hingegangen also bei uns im
kiez lebt jemand schon bestimmt schon
seit einem jahr auf der straße und hat
gefragt na ja warum arbeitest du nicht
du bist so jung du bist auch kräftig und
bist nicht krank er gesagt ja ich will
nicht arbeiten roboter können lust und
will auch nicht um zum abend will ich
alles nicht so weiter und ich finde wenn
ich mich selbst betrachte ich arbeite
seit meinem 16 lebensjahr und wenn ich
höre dass leute sagen ob die so dafür so
wenig arbeiten und ist ja alles
gar keine leistungen die berlin hat
steuerzahler ist es ja aber du siehst ja
ganz viele leute die quasi dann sagen
jaja es bringt ja alles gar nichts und
ich habe gar keine lust und dann moment
so sich da so raus und zweiter also ich
bin auch total dafür dass man quasi sagt
man ja wenn jemand nicht will oder keine
höheren tag so arbeiten willst dann
sollen die leute auch quasi sanktionen
kriegen weil warum sollen sie sich warum
soll man jetzt sagen da ist auch kein
problem dann wird halt zu hause müsse
alles in ordnung also ich bin da ganz
für und finde es auch sowieso was ich
bin zb ich kann sowieso nicht
nachvollziehen dass leute die arbeiten
wollen also ich will nur arbeiten ich
möchte mein ganzes leben lang von dem
leben was ich mache und kann gar nicht
nachvollziehen wie leute lust haben die
ganzen anti rutsch und auch in hartz4
rein also sind klar leute die keine lust
habe es gibt aus natürlich gibt
schicksale die sind einfach gekommen
ohne das ist viel dazu beigetragen haben
aber wenn du die leute sie ist die quasi
über 20 30 jahre arbeitslos sind oder
hartz iv empfangen und auch gar keine
lust mehr haben zu arbeiten naja und
dann quasi sich nicht wie du schon
gesagt dass nicht kooperativ zeigen wir
wie soll das weitergehen wenn es auch
sich so aus bürgert und immer weiter
wird und immer mehr wird und so wer soll
dass am ende alles bezahlen also wir
anderen was ich mich auch gefragt habe
auch gerne noch die rückfrage ansehen
was macht bei hartz4 ist es ja so dass
man auch erst hat hier bekommt wenn man
beispielsweise sein vermögen
aufgebraucht hat oder ein haus könnte
man da nicht ein system einführen was
ehrlicher etwas fairer ist weil mit den
sanktionen gebe ich ihnen recht ich sehe
das sehr ähnlich aber ich finde schon
manchmal wenn menschen beispielsweise 30
jahre gearbeitet haben und vielleicht
auch einfach kaputt sind dass die dann
dieselben leistung nur kriegen wie
jemand der mit 18 oder 19 ich arbeiten
will
hatte sie damals im bundestag bewegt
dass alle dasselbe bekommen sollen
dieses gleichmacher prinzip von hartz 4
wir hatten damals zum zeitpunkt als
schröder die hartz reform vorgestellt
hat ich hab ja damals im plenarsaal
gesessen ich habe mir die erschrockene
gesichter der eigenen genossinnen und
genossen er in zwei systeme wir hatten
die arbeitslosenhilfe und wir hatten die
sozialhilfe
arbeitslosenhilfe war von der tendenz
her höher warum
beitragsfinanzierten daten die
arbeitnehmer aber nimmer beiträge für
bezahlen die sozialhilfe war vom staat
finanziert jetzt wurde beide systeme
zusammengelegt und der entscheidende
satz von gerhard schröder war auf dem
niveau der sozialhilfe weil es 100
prozent vom steuerzahler finanziert wird
und deshalb zunächst mit vom
schonvermögen abgesehen das eigene
vermögen einsetzen bevor der
steuerzahler zur kasse gebeten wird
normal es geht hier nicht um
berufsunfähige gehe ich um gewerbs und
unfähige es sind ja auch von den
sanktionen überdurchschnittlich junge
männer betroffen diese
überdurchschnittlich betroffen sondern
es geht darum wenn der staat sagt wir
fördern deine integration auf dem
arbeitsmarkt durchbrach große durch
umschulungen durch weiterbildung auch
bitte termine wahrnehmen dann kann man
auch erwarten dass die
leistungsempfänger diese angebote des
staates nicht ausschlagen im übrigen
wenn man einmal vergleicht was gibt es
denn für zwei drei vier personen
haushalte im harz 4 besuch im
hartz-iv-bezug im vergleich zur
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
was die netto bekommen in vielen fällen
sind die unterschiedlich auch aufs knie
sogar ist ein aufsteiger an welche
arbeiten gericht gar nicht so groß und
dann sagen sich viele warum gehe ich
eigentlich arbeiten wenn wenn ich ohne
netto das gleiche bekommen denn bei der
integration auf dem arbeitsmarkt
vergleicht ja keiner sein jetziges
einkommen aus dem sozial bezug mit
seiner bruttoeinkommen sondern mit
seinem nettoeinkommen weil ich ja nur
vom netto einkaufen die miete bezahlen
da kommen natürlich jetzt die frage auf
frau petri ist deutschland zu gewusst zu
sehen
ich glaube wir haben
nicht nur in deutschland sondern überall
in der westlichen welt wo lange zeit ja
eine ganze menge geld zu teilen waren
vergleich zu entwicklungsländern immer
noch ist
einen entscheidenden fehler gemacht den
übrigen schon herr bismarck erkannt hat
schon der hat erkannt dass
sozialleistungen süßes gift sind und er
hat ja genau dann damit angefangen und
ist was viele nicht wissen dass es eine
entwicklung gegeben hat auch schon bevor
die bismarckschen reform einsetzen das
sogenannte genossenschaftsprinzip und
der genossenschaft prinzip wird immer
beinhaltet dass es für die die hilfe
brauchen in einer überschaubaren gruppe
wo man sich nämlich kennt und wo es eine
art sozialkontrolle gibt man sich
gegenseitig hilft wenn jemand in not
gerät und dieses prinzip der
gegenseitigkeit aber eben nur für die
bei denen ist nicht anders geht wo man
aber dann auch solidarisch zeigt das ist
im grunde durch die flächendeckende
einführung von sozialleistungen durch
den staat was zu einer natürlich
anonymisierung einem so großen land wie
deutschland gefühlen hat verloren
gegangen das heißt im grunde haben wir
durch die aufgabe des
genossenschaftsprinzip auf breiter ebene
ein anspruchsdenken geschaffen auf aber
überall in der gesellschaft würde hier
nicht nur auf hartz4 empfänger über die
wir reden mit ins boot nehmen sondern
viele andere die ist für normal halten
dass der staat irgendwas bezahlt und ich
habe den letzten jahren immer gesagt der
staat bezahlt überhaupt gar nichts
bezahlen tun die steuerzahler das heißt
die politiker sind nichts anderes und
leider vergessen sie das meistens als
treuhänder der steuergelder ihrer bürger
und wenn dieses bewusstsein bei einigen
mehr vorhanden wäre dann würden wir eine
andere politik machen ich würde nur eins
oben drauf setzen und sagen ich halte
grundsätzlich auch nichts davon einfach
geld auszureichen ohne gegenleistung da
bin ich ganz bei ihnen aber es gibt ein
es gibt ein modell und er sind die
vertreter des sogenannten
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens gar
nicht soweit hinweg von durchaus
liberalen vertretern die ein konzept vor
langer zeit in usa vorgeschlagen haben
das nennt sich negative einkommensteuer
ist die details werden zu kompliziert
angesagt ist ein steuerfreibetrag gründe
für alle und zwar als einsatz und das
ist der entscheidende punkt der aber
nicht gern gehört wird für alle
sozialleistungen das heißt man muss im
grunde über einen eine verschlankung und
eine vereinheitlichung von allen
möglichen sozialleistungen reden das
würde in der verwaltung am ende weniger
kosten und das würde dazu führen dass
das problem was herr bosbach beschrieben
hat dass arbeit sich im grunde nicht
lohnt dass sie die in teilzeitjobs
arbeit oder anfangen zu arbeiten am ende
weniger haben als diejenigen die sozial
bezug erhalten dass bei denen sich ab
dem ersten euro der dann auch versteuert
werden kann die arbeit wieder lohnt und
dahin müsste man aber das würde heißen
von vielen anderen sozialleistungen
abstand oder abschied zu nehmen und das
ist im grunde gratis
wir sind eine solidargemeinschaft der
staat springt ein wenn ich es alleine
nicht mehr schaffen und für die zu einer
solidargemeinschaft gehört auch dass
derjenige der etwas bekommt dann sich an
wenigstens eine mindestmenge gibt dafür
irgendetwas zu tun und dazu gehört der
gang zum amt wenn man jetzt nicht
schafft kann man anrufen kann sagen wenn
man schafft es nicht in berlin etwas
schwierig weil die verwaltung
funktioniert wirklich dass du das ist
die eigentliche hürde aber das andere
das kann man machen und heraus gesagt es
ist ein sehr kleiner teil nur also wer
hier den eindruck erweckt die
arbeitsämter würden mit unbilliger härte
große mengen von armen
hartz-iv-empfängern verfolgen das ist
nicht so die große mehrheit von denen
schafft ist ganz pro unproblematisch
sich dort zu melden und es wird auch
immer mehr vermittelt wir suchen
arbeitskräfte das ist alles
man möchte sich da einfach mit einem
bestimmten klientel
das demjenigen der spd und vielleicht
auch den grünen möchte man sich einfach
beliebt machen und wir sagen ihr müsst
euch nicht mehr so anstrengen
das ist ein langwieriges projekt was die
spd schon lange hatte und wie solche
sachen macht man lieber am anfang später
wird es dann immer schwieriger es sind
auch gar keine so schlimm sanktionen es
sind leute die sich hartnäckig
verweigern vorzusprechen und sich
vermitteln zu lassen die dann einfach
die die bezüge gekürzt bekommen das ist
also anders geht es nicht man muss sich
immer vergegenwärtigen dass auch eine
liebe verkäuferin die sehr knapp
verdient wenn sie nur 30 euro in die
arbeitslosenkasse einzahlt dann mit für
die anderen ein steht also die die
unteren gehaltsgruppen die arbeiten die
trifft es viel härter die abgaben zu
leisten damit sich leute die gar nicht
arbeiten
was bekommen also die haben eigentlich
auch einen anspruch darauf es ist
eigentlich ein sehr gerechtes system und
bei dem bürger geld oder es jetzt so
heißt früher bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen gefällt mir einfach die
psychologische botschaft nicht so zu
sagen wir leben bedingungslos
und irgendwer bezahlt uns und wenn wir
arbeiten ist gut wenn man nicht arbeiten
auch diese botschaft finde ich
lebensfern das funktioniert nirgends auf
der welt ist funktioniert nun da wo wir
eine glocke von sozialstaat über uns
haben zum beispiel auf einer insel
sitzen müssen wir ganz schön ackern um
da irgendwie zu überleben